[Música]
[Aplausos]
quiero que cierren los ojos todos y
remises
y que pongan sus manos en su corazón
y creen que esta oscuridad los invada
chimba a su cuerpo y que invada su mente
ahora quiero que imaginen una luz al
frente de sus ojos
- ahora
esa luz puede ser del color que ustedes
quieran su color preferido
ese color que les transmite paz y
tranquilidad
y vamos a dejar que esa luz fluya por
todo nuestro cuerpo
empezando por nuestra cabeza
bajando hacia nuestro corazón nuestros
pulmones
dejando la figuración nuestros brazos
nuestras manos nuestros dedos
respiren profundo
ec salen lentamente
ven que esa luz fluye hacia sus piernas
hacia sus pies
dejen que ría por todo su cuerpo
que los invade
los mba con luz con energía
respiren profundo
y salen lentamente
ahora en sus ojos
espero que hayan sentido mucha paz y
mucha tranquilidad
hoy los quiero llevar conmigo a un viaje
a 97 metros de profundidad
y en este viaje quiero que entiendan un
poco qué pasa por mi mente cuando a
tanta profundidad y tal vez se puedan
responder a esa pregunta que tanto me
hacen a sofía que le pasa por la mente
cuando deje de respirar y de sumarle a
lo más profundo del océano
entonces empecemos por los más
importantes por el principio respirar
y es que respirar es lo más importante
para poder dejar de respirar tenemos que
aprender a hacerlo muy bien y con estas
aprendemos a respirar tan bien que
podemos meter muchísimo más aire de lo
que una persona normal puede hacer vamos
a prepararnos quedan cinco minutos para
la inmersión
en este momento nuestro cuerpo y nuestra
mente entran en un estado de profundidad
de profundidad de pensamientos de
profundidad de respiración
y es que esa última respiración es la
más importante es la que nos va a llevar
la energía suficiente para bajar hasta
el fondo de la cuerda y poder volver a
la superficie
en mi mente se activan un montón de
cosas
una parte de mi mente está pendiente de
todo lo que pasa alrededor
cierro mis ojos me concentro
otra parte de mi mente está pendiente de
mi respiración empiezo a contar mis
respiraciones inhalen 5 4 3 2 1 y salen
10 987
5 4 3 2
y otra parte de mi mente está pendiente
del tiempo que me falta para empezar mi
inmersión
tres minutos dos minutos un minuto y
medio 1 minuto 30 segundos me preparo 20
segundos
15 segundos el salón totalmente
diez segundos comienzo a inhalar la
última inhalación profunda y completa
llene mis pulmones al máximo y comienzo
a empacar más aire
empacó tanto aire que mis pulmones
sienten que se van a salir del pecho
cada una de estas empacadas significa un
segundo menos para dejarte respirar
última empacada
estoy lista
me sumerjo
desde el momento en que mi cuerpo deja
la superficie mi mente se transporta a
un universo diferente no solo porque
estoy debajo del agua sino porque sea un
lugar de paz y de tranquilidad de
sensaciones nuevas
desde el momento que dejó la superficie
empieza a repetirme un mantra cuatro
palabras que dejan que mi mente fluya
que me dicen concentrado en lo que estoy
haciendo y que tratan de eliminar esos
pensamientos negativos que siempre están
presentes no crean que soy jedi pues si
es que ya late master en pensamientos
positivos
comienzo a bajar
por mi mente está ese mantra paz amor
tranquilidad azul
paz amor tranquilidad azul o trabajo en
mi cabeza va contando las patadas que
tengo que hacer yo en mi mente ya tengo
la estructura de una inmersión ya sé
cuantas patadas tengo que dar para
llegar a 10 a 20 a 30 metros de
profundidad
mateo pateo bateo
30 metros
en este momento será mi primera alarma
esta alarma que me avisa que tengo que
tomar aire en mis cachetes o en mi boca
para poder seguir compensando la presión
en mis oídos que cada vez que bajó un
metro más se vuelve más y más grande y
es que después de estos 30 metros mis
pulmones están tan comprimidos que sacar
aire de ellos es casi imposible ya está
peligroso
lleno mis cachetes
cierro mi glotis y ese es el tema
permitir más y más profundo sin romper
mis tímpanos
hasta ese momento la inmersión ha sido
totalmente física
tantas cosas que tengo que hacer
meticulosamente para que la inversión
sea perfecta tanto que hacer que me
queda muy poco tiempo para pensar
pero en este momento tengo tanta agua
encima de mi cuerpo que ya no floto más
me dejo ir
caigo como una piedra dejo que el agua
me llegue hasta el fondo
y aquí es donde mi mente se vuelve a
activar
usted van a aprender que tengo
transtorno de múltiples personalidades y
estas cosas pero esto lo que está
pasando por mi mente en este momento la
voz más fuerte que me repite el mantra
paz amor tranquilidad azul y vamos
malvada que está aquí diciéndome que
estás haciendo no lo vas a lograr tienes
que respirar de vuélvete ya
un segundo que yo deje que esa voz
malvada gane y mi inmersión se acaba
un segundo que decía que no soy capaz
agarrar la cuerda me impulso hacia
arriba y llegó a la superficie
sigo bajando la luz y hace cada vez más
tenue me concentro en mi cuerpo están
pasando un montón de adaptaciones
fisiológicas que permiten que vayamos a
tanta profundidad sin hacernos daño
la primera es el reflejo mamífero que
tenemos todos los mamíferos y que
consiste en que cuando nosotros nos
sumergimos en el agua el ritmo cardiaco
inmediatamente baja
a pulsaciones tan lentas como 20 o 15
por minuto esto hace que nuestro consumo
de oxígeno sea mucho menor y que podamos
aguantar la respiración por más tiempo
el cambio de la sangre que permite que
el plasma fluya libremente por los
tejidos y los órganos y que se vaya a
nuestros pulmones que están así de
comprimidos a nuestros alveolos para que
nuestros pulmones no colapsen
y la vasoconstricción periférica que
permite que la sangre se concentre en
esta parte del cuerpo en el cerebro y en
los órganos vitales y se vaya a las
extremidades
sigo bajando
50 metros
en ese momento los pensamientos
negativos se vuelven un poquito menos
fuertes
mi pensamiento más fuerte es ya estudia
50 metros
estoy muy profundo falta más si me
devuelvo que si sigo bajando hasta el
final
por nada te vas a devolver
la luz se hace cada vez más y más tenue
pero de la oscuridad no hay nada que ver
hacia afuera es un momento de mirar
hacia adentro un momento de reflexión y
de meditación y como diría la gran
natale murciano va una amistad increíble
la apnea es más que un deporte es una
manera de conocernos a nosotros mismos
sigo bajando en mi mente sigue mi mantra
paz amor tranquilidad azul y esa voz que
sigue diciendo me devuelve te eres una
fracasada no lo vas a lograr
paz amor tranquilidad azul suena mi
última alarma faltan 10 metros para
llegar a 97 metros de profundidad
esa alarma hace que salgo un poco del
trance en el que estoy y que vuelva a
estar alerta alerta para llegar al fondo
y no pegarme con el plato porque sería
un golpe durísimo en la cabeza
llegó al fondo agarró a mi testigo me
impulso hacia arriba y comienza a subir
y en ese momento mi mente y mi cuerpo se
activan
ya no puedo seguir cayendo ya no me
puedo dejar llevar por el agua ahora sé
que tengo que nadar con fuerza y
determinación para poder llegar a la
superficie de nuevo
y ahora mi mantra es en cada patada que
oí paz amor tranquilidad azul y ahora
mis pensamientos negativos se tornan un
poquito más trágico es esto es muy
profundo se te va a acabar el aire no lo
vas a lograr pero por cada patada que
doy paz amor tranquilidad azul sigo
subiendo a luz se hace cada vez más y
más fuerte y el agua vez que el agua
cada vez más y más cálida sé que falta
poco para llegar paz amor tranquilidad
azul 30 metros me encuentro con mis
artistas de seguridad en las personas
que me van a acompañar esos últimos
metros de la inversión que son los más
críticos críticos porque yo más de dos
minutos sin respirar porque acabo de
someter a mi cuerpo a una presión diez
veces mayor a la que nos vemos sometidos
en la superficie
porque mis pulmones vuelven a expandirse
y esa sangre que está rica en oxígeno
ese oxígeno que paso tan fuerte por
difusión a la sangre
los pulmones solo vuelven a robar
entonces mis órganos y mis músculos
deben trabajar con mucho menos oxígeno
en el que tenían disponible pero en mi
mente yo ya lo logré estos últimos
metros son de disfrute total mi cuerpo
vuelve a ser positivo volver a patear
con mucha más tranquilidad me dejo
llevar por el agua
la luz se vuelve cada vez más y más
fuerte y sé que ya voy a llegar a la
superficie últimos 10 metros de la
inmersión
me dejo llevar por el agua dejo que
fluya me preparo salva la superficie de
mi mente lo único que está pasando es
respira respira
cuatro bocanadas de aire las más
importantes para que ese oxígeno vuelva
a llegar a todos mis tejidos a todos mis
músculos y a mi cerebro
lo logré
la vida es como una inmersión
[Aplausos]
la vida es como una inmersión es un
universo diferente para cada uno de
nosotros que el momento se puede volver
más y más oscuro y podemos tener
pensamientos que nos hagan creer que no
somos capaces que debemos rendirnos que
somos unos fracasados pero está en cada
uno de nosotros tocar fondo [ __ ]
fuerzas para volver a salir a la luz y
volver a respirar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]